what's going on guys
so Godzilla is about to awake from his
slumber and karora back into movie
theaters and that got me thinking what
are the coolest movie monsters of all
time we brought in a couple of monster
experts to talk about that very subject
first he is the founder of I mockery
calm and the creator of video games
abobo's big adventure and Bionic
Chainsaw Pogo gorilla it's Roger Bart
ooh mouthful I know and he is the main
monster at mad monster calm welcome back
evan magar thanks for having me back
yeah good to see you buddy so he call
Godzilla the king of the monsters let's
talk about some of the some of the Dukes
and Earls and princes of monster dome
Evan are there any that stand out to you
that are just pretty awesome you know as
much as I love the old-school monsters I
was really happy with Cloverfield
I love the Cloverfield monster I loved
its mouth with it was very predator in
the mouth with their and also had what
would you call those inflatable sex yeah
I kind of like like a frog like a toad
or something oh yeah I love that very
that was a great addition um are there
any uh larger scale monsters kaijus that
are you're a fan of Roger um I would say
the graboids from tremors just seeing
these giant worms come up from
underground with all these crazy
tentacle things coming out of their
mouths and grabbing on to you that's a
good movie let's let's talk about King
Kong for a second right so some people
call King Kong the American Godzilla
it's an American product it was um you
know started here the common thread is
is you basically have us you know this
sympathetic displaced beast that really
isn't out to hurt anybody it just finds
itself in a new situation there's like
an Iron Giant quality to King Kong cuz
you didn't want to hurt anybody was just
ripped out of his surroundings now but
Godzilla he came back to wreck shop a
little bit see I wouldn't even say that
it's wreck shop I think if like you woke
up in a foreign land and unbeknownst to
you there's this tiny micro village
outside and you just step out did you
see what's going on and by the time you
make it five feet thousands of people
are dead you know you're gonna you're
gonna breathe fire on it though does
that go with well I think once they
start shooting like hey what I do I'll
throw it out love to hear thoughts on
the Kraken I'm just gonna mention that
that's yeah it's at the top of my list
yeah talk to me about the Kraken we're
talking about the original Clash of the
Titans not the 81 the Harryhausen Ray
Harryhausen exactly
you know I guess he's almost like Merman
from the messes of the universe Meets
The Creature from the Black Lagoon on
his giant he's pretty adorable you don't
want to see the crack and get get beat
but yeah yeah he's pretty lovable
speaking of 1981's Clash of the Titans
there are so many amazing monsters in
that movie are you sure yes Medusa
Medusa yeah a master one of true masters
of monster making any other favorite
monsters carpenters thing is great
carpenters thing is pretty much the
creature creation that I think you have
to hold all other creature creations
against I mean that is what you judge
them Acropolis is just amazing yeah he's
an amazing creature work on that so
we've talked about a lot of the giant
monsters I'd love to shift gears and
talk about smaller scale monsters what
constitutes a monster
I basically think if it's something
that's killing people and it's not a
person by that rationale jaws would be a
monster is jaws a monster again I I
guess by that definition but you got to
remember like house of Dracula they had
a poor hunchback nurse and they counted
her five times the monsters and it's
just like hunchback nurse it's like she
has a physical disability so it's like
close enough you know I love what we're
doing here let's play a quick game of
monster not monster tell me the Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man from ghostbusters
monster now I'm gonna have to agree
monster
Frankenstein not a monster
they call him Frankenstein's monster
well that's what the village is called
but it right of the day if he would if
he woke up and they just had like
episodes of Seinfeld ready to go for him
and he just sat him in the corner and
just relaxed his impulse with him in to
get up and kill some okay um the Wolfman
yeah I'm gonna say monster yeah Dracula
yes
monsters the mummy yeah monster yeah
sure
gizmo is gizmo a monster gizmos more
like a pet strike Oh monster terminator
that's more like a robot yeah I put them
next to Mechagodzilla yeah anything
man-made it's one Declassified machine
robot yeah mm-hmm
the Leprechaun use the monster yeah he's
definitely a monster even in the hood so
it's uh let's do a little bit of vs.
okay I'm gonna throw some combinations
at you and you tell me which monster
would still be standing we established
earlier Godzilla's the king all right
let's put Godzilla aside Cloverfield
monster versus King Kong I would just
like to think that King Kong would have
a shot is agility swinging around yeah I
mean if a nuke couldn't take out Koller
field I mean what Snape gonna do
Cloverfield
versus the Kraken I don't think Neptune
would have had to keep Cloverfield
locked up I mean there's something when
a god has to keep you like locked up
that's a big deal I'd give it to the
Kraken cuz it's not fun to say
unleash the Cloverfield monster that's
not fun to say alright what about this
one eight morphed gremlins versus an
alien
gremlins are they can be really annoying
and yeah yeah yeah just thing they can
cause a lot of chaos and havoc and all
but it depends on environment cuz if
they get wet they could have backup
instantly that's true I would just take
a water go and keep squirt myself like
right yeah give me a minute okay let's
sit there no water around it's just 8/8
gremlins versus an alien I'm gonna have
to give it to the alien yeah sure
okay agree well troll versus leprechaun
leprechaun witch witch troll are we
talking about troll two trolls
nilbog
backwards I'm just gonna say those
trolls just for the fun of it jaws vs.
The Creature from the Black Lagoon
I think the creature could do it all
right he could trick jaws isn't it he
might not be able to kill him but I
don't think he would let jaws catch him
so what you're saying is he'd get away
from jaws you're not saying he would
defeat him he could possibly defeat with
those claws he could easily blind jaws
just like tear away at his eyes maybe
get into his gills or something like
that but but they have a great sense of
smell sharks so I don't think blinding
jaws would really yeah but jaws is also
pretty huge so all creature has to do is
find like a little spot so again you say
you can get away get away yeah yeah I
don't rush it is like you know who could
run away from the I know some
competitively win I think you guys need
to like go to a diner when after we stop
being really mature like this is a fight
for the game
it is I want it you're right about not
who could amicably come to it I love
this like Jim nerding out about this
stuff is the best one man yes the fact
that you guys took that seriously the
best the best what's your favorite
monster of all time leave an answer in
the comment section below tell us why
and the most monstrous answer will get a
screen junkies t-shirt
I want to thank my awesome guest Roger
Barr Evan magar love you guys your names
rhyme thank you for being here we're
buddy cups thanks for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter by like Jack breaks into the
Chinese consulate it's caught and fakes
his own death with the help of Chloe and
Tony hey
what are friends for if not to hope you
faked your own death